living under a blockade in yemen's third
largest city thais is a burden ahmed has
been dealing with for years
the challenges are many
visiting relatives who live beyond city
limits is just one of them
i live about one kilometer away from my
family but because of the blockade i
have to go through rough and dangerous
roads it takes me about five hours to
get to my parents house to see my mother
and father
road closures have left thousands of
people with limited access to medicine
proper medical services and
international aid
the blockade imposed by houthi rebels in
2016 has essentially closed off the main
routes that lead to the city making an
already dire humanitarian
crisis worse
protests demanding an end to the
blockade have failed a recent u.n
brokered truce was extended in early
june for two months it's noticeably
reduced tensions between houthi rebels
and the saudi-led coalition but the city
remains closed and its fragile economy
is feeling the hit
row closures have led to a spike in the
price of goods
transporting costs with trucks is a
serious problem
drivers have to go through rugged
terrain and distant roads it's yet
another added burden
about
000 people live here isolation from the
rest of the country and the world is
taking its toll
if a merchant orders 100 boxes of eggs
he can expect about 10 of them to be
damaged because of the rough roads so
that automatically means extra costs and
then there's the money that must be paid
at checkpoints
for years people living here have been
shut out
now they hope the truth will help change
that
katya lopez of the yen al jazeera